how you feeling today well it's just a
thrill to be able to acknowledge Carrie
that's the most important thing it's all
about her what do you think she would
think of all this oh she'd love it
and if she were here she'd make
she'd be making us all laugh
but I'm determined not to be sad because
this is really a happy day
[Music]
short for a stormtrooper
oh the uniform
I'm Luke Skywalker I'm here to rescue
you hello everyone
[Applause]
today
May the 4th be Carrie Francis Fisher day
I am so
happy to be here
with Billy with so many of my Star Wars
colleagues love you too
I met Carrie
when she was 19 years old
I've been over filming for about a month
and we arranged to have a dinner
so that we could meet each other and I'm
thinking she's 19 years old I mean she's
fairly out of high school I was a
worldly 24.
and
every expectation I had was just
obliterated
she was
so Charming
so funny
so adorable so wise Beyond her years I I
just couldn't believe it and brutally
Frank
she started telling me stories intimate
stories about her family that I'm
thinking should I be hearing this
I mean these were things that I would
probably not tell friends
unless I knew them for years
but that was Carrie she also had a
wisdom that seemed to
be
far beyond what a 19 year old should be
expected to have now I talked to Billy I
said it's gonna be really hard to come
up with words
to uh
do her justice you know I'm so pleased
that we're here to honor her Legacy and
her
her accomplishments but
I got out a notebook
and I was going to write down some of my
thoughts but then I found
what I wrote six years ago
not long after we lost her
and I thought
this is as relevant today as it was when
I wrote it
and what I wrote was
Carrie was one of a kind who belonged to
us all
whether we liked it or not
she was our princess damn it and the
actress who played her blurred into one
gorgeous fiercely independent and
ferociously funny take charge woman who
took our Collective breath away
determined and tough but with a
vulnerability that made you root for her
and want her to succeed and be happy
she played such a crucial role in my
professional and personal life
and both would have been far emptier
without her was she a handful
was she high maintenance Oh No Doubt
but everything would have been
so much drabber and less interesting
if she wasn't
she hadn't been the friend that she was
I'll never stop missing her
but I'm so thankful we had her as long
as we did I'm grateful for the laughter
the wisdom the kindness
and even the bratty self-indulgent crap
my beloved space twin drove me crazy
with through the years
so thank you Carrie
I love you
[Applause]
I can't say any more than that
I know it's sad that she's not with us
today that would have made it perfect
but she wouldn't want us to be sad
she'd want us to have fun she she'd want
us to laugh she had that sort of
anti-main ability to seize every day and
make the most of every moment
that she had
so thank you all for coming
thank you Billy and thank you Carrie
Francis Fisher
foreign